si les téléspectateurs marocains qui
nous rejoignent et qui vont suivre avec
nous cette émission spéciale qui sera
relayée dans 25 pays d'europe et du
maghreb par la chaîne tv5 par satellite
alors quelques précisions magie français
qui nous regardent ce soir n'est pas à
nous voir officier en dehors de notre
studio de l'heure de vérité et surtout
qu'il pas habitué à ce soir dialoguer
avec un roi
il faut dire majesté que toujours pour
le public français que vous n'êtes pas
un chef d'état comme les autres vous
êtes à la fois le chef spirituel et le
chef temporel du royaume du maroc d'une
part vous êtes l'héritier d'une dynastie
qui règne ici dans ce pays depuis trois
cent trente ans et d'autre part vous
êtes descendants du prophète et
commandeur des croyants
cela signifie que vous êtes investi
d'une double mission veiller au respect
de l'islam et veiller au respect de la
constitution que vous avez vous même
donné à ce pays en vertu de cette
constitution
votre personne et sacrée et inviolable
et quiconque s'attaque qu'à votre
majesté comme est un sacrilège et doit
expier son crime
l'effondrement du communisme est en
train de changer la géographie de
l'europe est en train de changer
l'équilibré du monde vous dirai comment
vous analysez ces bouleversements
et quelle conséquence ils peuvent avoir
pour les pays du sud de la méditerranée
je rappelle que vous êtes en ce moment
président du sommet de la ligue des 21
pays arabes et c'est à ce titre que vous
allez rencontrer le président de la
communauté européenne
monsieur mitterrand mais majesté ce soir
ce n'est pas seulement la vie du chef
d'état que me solliciteront c'est aussi
le jugement du commandeur des croyants
comment voyez-vous dans l'avenir la
coexistence de la communauté
judéo-chrétienne et de la communauté
islamique
c'est un problème qui vous le savez est
d'une grande actualité en france où ils
alimentent de dangereuses tensions 1,6
alors pour vous interroger ce soir sur
tout cela
dans cette salle
palais royal de rabat nous avons alain
duhamel jean daniel directeur du nouvel
observateur
albert du roy mais aussi à paris nous
avons geneviève moll qui centralise les
questions posées par téléphone et par
minitel la parole tout de suite aux
téléspectateurs avoue geneviève moll
avoué ce bp bonsoir majesté les français
sont bien sûr très préoccupés par ces
questions de religion et je vais vous
poser si vous le permettez la première
question d'une femme
la voici les femmes marocaines ne
portent pas tout le voile les musulmans
traditionalistes en france nous disent
que ce voile est essentiel au respect de
la religion musulmane
où est la vérité d'abord je voudrais
dire f bonsoir madame molle et à travers
elle à toutes les personnes qui au cours
de cette émission voudront bien me poser
les questions
je tiens à remercier l'organisation de
d'antenne 2 pour ce qu'elle a fait
perdre en quelques jours et je pense que
de ce dialogue tridimensionnelle nous
nous en tirons tous avec un certain
profit en ce qui me concerne je parlerai
très franchement de tout concernant tous
les sujets que l'on posera
partant du principe que comme le disait
pascal vérité au delà des pyrénées et
revendre ça et que ma foi ni le maroc
d'une part ni la france d'autre part
quelques séculaire que soit leur
histoire ne saurait être la source du
droit au la source de la sagesse ou de
la loi il vend la bhl et l'inaltérable
et là je peux dire concernant cette
question que
effectivement la majorité des femmes
marocaines ne porte pas le voile
de plus en plus non pas qu'elle ait
l'impression que nous avons l'impression
quand cela elles contreviennent au haut
commandement de l'islam car les
commandants dix commandements d'islam
concernant le port du voile sont
définies dans le temps et dans l'espace
comme nous le verrons car je pense que
ce n'est pas la seule question qui ne
sera posée concernant des traditions
musulmanes surtout lorsqu'elles sont
appliquées en pays non musulmans
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que en plus
quand on a demandé aux deux jeunes
filles marocaines
quand je leur ai fait demander
personnellement en tant que père de
famille par l'intermédiaire de mon
ambassadeur de vouloir bien cesser cette
affaire dont elle était à l'origine sans
le vouloir
elles ont parfaitement compris et leurs
parents aussi bien que bien que bien que
d'après les photos que j'ai vues
il s'agit là puis s'agissait là plus de
fiches eu que deux voix et je pense que
la question je pense que vous n'aurez
plus conseils pour déposer au conseil
d'état aurait dû être précédée
a montreuil amim ce maurice brouillon
secrétaire perpétuel de l'académie
française pour lui demander des
précisions le jour du jeudi puisque
c'est le jour du dictionnaire sur la
signification du mot voile enfin grâce à
dieu l'avis du conseil d'état a été des
plus conciliant et je retrouve la main
ma vieille mon honorable et respectable
famille du droit administratif et du
droit constitutionnel français vient de
donges et les plus éminents professeurs
avec alain duhamel pour un quart d'heure
avec duhamel qui a beaucoup de questions
bon ça n'est pas interdite mais je pose
ma femme mais même pour mes invités vous
allez alors vous savez que en france le
problème des la coexistence entre les
principes de l'islam est une société
lake comme la nôtre soulève en ce moment
beaucoup de controverses et même
beaucoup de passion alors la première
question qu'au fond on se pose tous les
uns et les autres aient laquelle je
voudrais que vous répondiez
succinctement si vous le pouvez parce
qu'on suggère un tas de questions
ponctuelles à vous poser c'est de savoir
est-ce que vous qui êtes à la fois un
monarque et en même temps le commandeur
des croyants est ce que vous pensez
sincèrement qu'il peut y avoir une
coexistence harmonieuse entre de bons
musulmans qu'ils respectent les lois de
l'islam est une société laïque comme la
france dans lequel ils se trouvent mais
tout à fait naturellement de restent nos
sociétés en cohabiter pendant pendant
des siècles avant la laïcité depuis le
maïs it et pas toujours facilement enfin
grâce à dieu disons paisiblement
paisiblement depuis des depuis des
siècles disons depuis le légendaire
la légendaire histoire de poitiers est
hypothétique
hypothétiquement fait depuis longtemps
vécu et je pense que dans cette affaire
du voile
il veut venir nous aller et venir en
dehors de pandore de ce que ce diable
qui nous est sorti de cette boîte
je me demande qu'on tue les français
jusqu'à présent a reproché à la société
musulmane en france lake le maximum
maximorum utt par exemple le jour de la
fête de l'aïd el kébir le sacrifice du
mouton et jusqu'à présent on n'a jamais
reçu de protestation de la société
protectrice des animaux
et pourtant c'est anna pts qui
représente le sacrifice d'abraham autour
duquel nous retrouvons tous donc très
clairement en ce qui vous concerne
avec l'expérience et la compétence qui
est la vôtre vous considérer qu entre
d'un côté un état de droit et de droit
des gens comme la france et selon les
règles de la france et d'autre par
l'observation des règles de bon musulman
il n'y a pas de contradiction
sauf si on veut le sauver si on veut les
créer oui mais pas naturellement bon
alors justement venons en brièvement
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres aspects
des choses tous les problèmes de
l'immigration qui sont très importants
mais venons en brièvement à cette
affaire du voile de quelques jeunes
musulmanes d'ailleurs parce que s'est
posée pour un petit nombre de jeunes
filles musulmanes qui ont souhaité pour
pouvoir porter pendant leur classe ce
qu'on a appelé les foulards coranique
alors votre réponse à vous 7
est ce que oui ou non c'était pour elle
obligatoire est ce que pour être de
bonne musulmane elle était obligée de le
faire ou non
d'abord c'est la première fois que
j'entends parler de foule à coranique
vous avez lu la presse française
je sais que vous la lisez beaucoup et je
crois que vous avez retrouve le
l'explosion à certain nombre de noirs et
franchement parce que si je l'avais lu
je re immédiatement émis une fatwa édit
si toi c'est l'arrêt désolé mais c'est
un sacrilège que de mettre les saintes
écritures sur des tissus qui peuvent
être souillée qu'on le veuille ou non
non papa sow
soumillon mais par de l'huile par des
mains malpropre donc il ne saurait y
avoir de vouloir wade il faut la
bonapartiste des coq et des assiettes et
des pipe comme des héros ce temps mais
il n'y a pas j'aime les ud foulard que
ronnie dont donc il n'y a pour une jeune
musulmane qui est en france et qui suit
les cours de son école en france il
n'est pas question de porter un voile
sous une forme ou sous une autre
quel que soit le nom qu'on lui donne on
peut là peut pas l'interdire pour tes
fiches hisser là des bigoudis ce jour là
et je crois que c'est elle aussi je suis
quelques rixes qui n'est pas recommandée
en classe d'accord enfin alors il ya un
autre problème qui a été soulevé à ce
sujet et qui était de savoir si toujours
pour des jeunes filles musulmanes qui
veulent respecter leur religion ce qui
est tout à fait honorable
il est possible ou non souhaitable ou
non d'être dispensé de certains cours
comme par exemple les sciences
naturelles le on a parlé du dessin on a
parlé à la natation
bref tout ce qui pouvait de près ou de
loin être susceptibles de représenter le
corps est ce que ça pose un problème en
fait c'est vraiment couper les cheveux à
vous êtes d'accord que ça a été posée
mais écoutez mes filles mes filles ont
fait de la natation ou fête du basket en
short on joue au tennis en en jupe de
tennis on tue le sport en matière à
option mes soeurs du temps de mon père
ma petite fille les parents de toul de
tous les marocains de toute extraction
ouvriers ne compte ne comprendrais pas
qu'on vienne les amputés de quelques
chose que les religions droits reconnus
à condition qu'il n'y ait pas
naturellement provocation et vos maux de
la société
alors revenons en au problème plus large
parce qu'aussi bien la question des
dites des foulards était une question
qui portait à stephen hoiles cette
histoire de fous là mais c'est ce
qu'apple on appellerait un des amis s'y
présente la désinformation
alors revenons aux problèmes plus
généraux qui sont liées à l'immigration
d'abord est-ce que vous même sir est ce
que vous êtes favorable ou non parce que
aujourd'hui il y est une forme
d'immigration par exemple du maroc vers
la france
je ne peux mieux citer que les paroles
que vous a dit le président de la
république monsieur françois mais tombe
qui vous a parlé non seulement nombre
d'états mais en homme généreux et un
homme de droit quand il a parlé du droit
des gens dans la dernière émission jeu à
dimanche dernier avec beaucoup d'intérêt
je suis contre l'immigration clandestine
parce qu'elle n'avance ni le pays
exportateurs ni pays importe est sans
vais revenir
nous ne nous perdons le cordon ombilical
au départ nous et à l'arrivée ce qui
ressort deuxièmement l'information que
nous recherchons car quand nous envoyons
des ouvriers nous recherchons une
promotion sociale pour eux quand ils
reviennent contremaître de telle usine
ou de tel complexe sidérurgique ou autre
c'est pour nous à nagui donc je suis
pour l'expo leur l'exportation de la
main de l'immigration contrôle et plus
et les contrôler plus naturellement
puisque c'est le cas de la france
dépendant de la france la france sera
plus les vôtres discuter avec nos ce
monde des conditions de vie de ces
marocains y compris leur vie religieuse
et communautés alors que comme vous
l'avez entendu dimanche dernier quand on
l'interrogé le président françois
mitterrand
il avait exprimé trois principes
le premier principe effectivement qui en
france a été tout à fait ressenti comme
de sa part disons au moins une
modification de son attitude
ça a été justement dans la fermeté de la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
alors puisqu'on a la chance d'être avec
vous qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
concrètement pour compliquer les choses
à ceux qui veulent poursuivre
l'immigration clandestine parce qu'il y
en aura toujours qui ne voudront des
deux côtés au maroc et en france
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
leur compliquer la vie c'est écoutez je
ne peux pas vous donner de de mesures
précises
est-ce que vous avez une demande par
exemple vis-à-vis de la france après
tout peut-être que la france ait quelque
chose qu'elle fait mal et que coûte et à
partir du moment où nous sommes d'accord
qu'il ya un problème sur un aspect
particulier de
question jusqu'à présent on en avait
parlé de son plan sentimental sur plan
viscérale sur plan politique momentanée
conjoncturelle et autres maintenant on
veut en parler scientifiquement tenté de
complice à appliquer des règles
scientifiques à la nature humaine même
et c'est déjà un grand pas de fait je
pense que nous devrions mettre une
cellule de réflexion et d'action
concernant ce problème qu'ils puissent
comprendre la condition de la ville le
ministère de l'intérieur la sécurité
sociale et le mystère n'approuve la de
la formation professionnelle et
sincèrement est-ce que vous considérez
que en ce qui concerne la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine entre disons
les méthodes de charles pasqua que vous
connaissez et les méthodes de son
successeur pierre joxe qui sont deux
ministres appartenant à deux majorités
différentes en france
je veux pas vous faire dire quel est le
meilleur et le plus mauvais vous me
diriez que vous ne voulez pas gêné de
problème avec aucun doute
alors c'était pareil pour vous c'est du
pareil au même pour moi c'était pareil
les problèmes existent il existe
toujours
pasqua jacques ça c'est même combat non
c'est mes problèmes
ces mêmes problèmes dont le style c'est
l'homme comme disait pascal chacun prend
la poêle par le côté qui l'intéressent
ou peu importe c est le style quand est
ce que vous le définiriez en
l'occurrence de l'un et de l'autre
comme je vous le disais le maréchal foch
à d'une parole qui est extraordinaire et
j'aimerais que tous ceux qui ont une
décision à prendre puis cela jamais
l'oublier de quoi s'agit-il
en fait nous tombons sur de quoi s'agit
alors qu'il ya une autre question que
françois mitterrand a abordé dimanche
dernier de façon très claire et qui est
pour les immigrés cette fois ci qui se
trouvent en france cette fois ci en
situation régulière
pour cela son souhait son désir est son
programme
c'est ce que nous appelons l'intégration
alors est-ce que vous de votre point de
vue c'est une bonne chose est ce que
vous considérez que les familles et les
travailleurs marocains en situation
régulière qui se trouvent en france qui
sont nombreux doivent chercher à
s'intégrer à la société française bien
ce que vous considérez que c'est d'une
certaine façon une adjurations je suis
vous vous êtes contre vous êtes content
oui
pourquoi pour la simple raison que pour
moi il n'y a pas de marocains nés au
maroc élevé au maroc et des marocains
nés en france et élevés en france
les deux sont électeurs éligibles et
quand j'ai dit aux marocains marché et
qu'ils ont marché surtout quand je dis
arrêtez vous et eux sont arrêtés
elle vous parle là vous parlez de la
marche verte oui alors je pouvoir que
l'échec revenant on puisse retrouver
cette fille ivre et celle là se dilue en
dehors de la patrie elle s'enrichit
certainement mais il se dit lui je suis
contre l'intégration dans un sens ou
dans un autre
alors est ce que vous êtes favorable ou
opposé au droit puisque c'est une
question qui comme vous le savez très
bien et beaucoup discuté en france en ce
moment au droit des étrangers qui se
trouvent en france quelle que soit
d'ailleurs leur origine de vote 2
pouvoir voter un jours pour l'instant ce
n'est pas possible mais un jour et aux
élections locales ou pas je suis
franchement je suis content je les dis
devant le président de la république
lui-même ou semi 30 quand j'ai reçu à
paris au cercle interallié au cercle
militaire à paris devant la colonie
marocaine mais lassant devant tous les
français
comment là ce sont devant tous les
français et y avait des français ça a
été repris non large dire ce soir et
jeudi
je leur dis vous n'avez pas à vous
remplir la tête et l'esprit le soir en
allant dormir de problèmes électoraux
qui sont pas légaux car en définitive
vous n'êtes pas français
on cherchera toujours vos voix pour un
apport et on vous oubliera par la suite
et vous n'aurez même pas la pudeur nous
je les connais les morgues ils sont
pudiques n'iront même pas le lendemain
demandé leur obole alors c'est pas la
peine ça ne marchera pas c'est pas là
mais alors à partir du moment
je m'excuse je pense loyer interne à rue
ça nous mènera à des magouilles à des à
des magouilles les sages ne veut pas les
relations entre le peuple français le
peuple marocain ou toujours été ce
qu'elles sont et on s'est affronté on
s'est embrassés on n'a jamais magouilles
et je veux qu'on en reste et est ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu à partir du moment
où
considérer que l'intégration n'est ni
souhaitable ni possible ce soit à terme
gros risques de conflits de coexistence
difficile mais j'ai audio une chose vous
avez devant vous à l'intégrer
cent-pour-cent c'est à dire je pense que
je suis intégré dans la société
française dans le raisonnement français
dans ce que peuvent penser les français
aimer ou ne pas aimer les français mais
je ne sais pas pour ça que je vais lever
mon dos je vais le droit mais vous
n'êtes vous reconnaîtrez sire que vous
n'êtes pas absolument typiques comme on
n'est pas absolument typique vous à 10
ans prévue les jeunes ont la leur
indépendance ils ont le problème
non disons que je suis d'une génération
qui devient atypique
j'ai eu la chance la même génération et
moi d'avoir une éducation une formation
que nous n'avons plus mais enfin ça va
nous relancer dans la francophonie et
les échanges culturels c'est pas la
peine c'est un autre dossier d'enfer
nous sommes bien intégrés mais tout en
restant et est alors parce que ça c'est
une question que en france je prends ne
se pose pas assez est ce que vous
considérez que les travailleurs
marocains et leurs familles qui sont en
france sont traités de façon équitable
ou pas parce qu'en france évidemment on
se demande toujours si eux se comporte
de façon équitable ou pas mais il ya un
autre aspect des choses
est-ce que de votre point de vue ils
sont traités de façon équitable non vous
voulez une réponse proche à us oui
absolument c'est la règle de l'émision
et bien voilà je pense que là où vous
allez et c'est pour ça que je ne veux
pas que mes paroles soient considérés
comme blessants tenus par les uns ou par
les autres
mais quelques français que vous prenez
qu'il soit au sud-est au sud ouest en
corse dans le nom particulièrement ou
dans la vallée du rhône quand vous dites
alors le marocain aziz a si tous étaient
comme les manques et shendi peu plus
alors il ya un état de fait aujourd'hui
qu'ils existent il ya un état de fait et
qui est que beaucoup d'argent existe
dans la communauté européenne même s'il
y en a pas assez pour tout le monde même
si le niveau de vie n'est pas encore
suffisant mais disons que en gros il est
quand même très élevé et qu'en revanche
à beaucoup d'hommes qui sont dans le
maghreb avec un taux de natalité très
élevé et que ont un niveau de vie qui
est moindre est ce que vous croyez que
dans ces conditions avec si j'ose dire
en simplifiant beaucoup d'à côté
l'argent et de l'autre côté les hommes
est ce que vous croyez qu'on peut
espérer vraiment durablement stabiliser
les populations là où elle se trouve
je pense je pense personnellement parce
que tout est une question d'ambition
tout une question d'ambition si ceux
chez qui nous allons travailler nous
font travailler avec l'ambition de nos
promouvoir de le donner une formation il
ne renverrons pas des citrons pressés
ils renverront des gens qui dans des
ateliers de formation pour en être
formateur eux mêmes et la dignité la
dignité humaine s'en trouvera revalorisé
c'est une valeur ajoutée
ce serait une valeur ajoutée
c'est-à-dire que pour vous le bond entre
guillemets travailleurs immigrés c'est
en réalité celui qui va acquérir une
formation professionnelle supplémentaire
exactement et qui revient chez lui et
qui oblige merci alain duhamel majesté
est ce que vous accepteriez de recevoir
jean marie le pen
comment est-ce que vous accepteriez de
recevoir jean marie le pen comme ça pour
le plaisir mais par mai
parler de quoi vous savez moi je ne
quand on est président du sommaire avec
un e reçu
ce shimon perez ou pour recevoir j'ai
une courage les opinions les jours où je
penserai comme c'est jean marie le pen
peut m'apporter quelque chose où je peux
peut-être le ramener sur certaines de
ses idées de majesté pendant que vous
dialoguez avec alain duhamel nous avons
fait un certain nombre de sondages le
service d'études politiques la sofres a
fait des sondages auprès de
l'échantillon représentatif de la
population
la première question qui est posée steam
et vous que le roi hassan ii a bien fait
d'intervenir auprès des ressortissants
marocains dans la sphère du voile
islamique
soixante dix huit pour cent des français
interrogés approuvent votre intervention
12% seulement la désapprouvent
car il s'agissait d'un problème
intérieur français sans opinion 10%
un commentaire je sais ce résultat alors
nous allons quand même
nous allons quand même diffusé le
résultat du second où la question était
la religion islamique est elle selon
vous que s'ils ont posé un public
français bien entendu la religion
islamique est elle selon vous
conciliable avec les lois françaises oui
42% non 49 % sans opinion 9% toujours
pas de commentaire ici un pardon oui je
pense que le la couleur du milieu qui le
nom ce sont deux qu'ils appartiennent à
un clash laïque mais keane qui ne
comprend pas la profondeur de laïcité et
qui ont fait un mur
c'est peut-être mais compréhensive bien
majesté nous allons asvp pour une autre
question
geneviève moll tout à fait majesté que
pensez-vous après tout ce que vous venez
de dire des mariages mixtes
je ne viens vous faut répéter votre
question mais j'étais que pensez-vous
après tout ce que vous venez de dire des
mariages mixtes au madame ce que je
pense des mariages mixtes est très clair
c'est que c'est vraiment le calcul des
probabilités le plus improbable pour un
qui réussit il y en a cent qui échoue je
pense qu'il est préférable de de laisser
les choses aller comme elles sont
sans être ni pour ni contre mais tout au
moins il faut quand même considérer
l'environnement il faut compte il ya
beaucoup qu'on parle tous actuellement
d'environnement mais l'environnement
beaucoup plus important il ya
l'environnement historique l
environnement l'authenticité à
l'environnement
tout court et l'envoi et l'environnement
continental linguistiques religieux je
sais que je dis je ne recommande pas les
mariages mixtes ni ni dans un sens ni
dans un autre
jusqu'à présent n'ont pas donné des
résultats escomptés
jean-daniel pour un quart d'heure jean
daniel directeur du nouvel observateur
j'ai beaucoup de questions à vous poser
mais je ne les ya les ig ont d'habitude
comme d'habitude dans les vignes je vais
essayer je sais je reviens une seconde
sur sur l'islam oui parce que c'est vrai
que el assa dimensions cocasses
peut-être qu lente comme vous l'avez
position est extrêmement nettes dans
certaines manifestations elle a évoqué
tout de même quelque chose de profond
voulais vous parler plus facile dans des
manifestations qui ont eu lieu à ce
propos cette affaire a eu quand même
quelque chose de profond dans la mesure
où elle avait évoqué le sort les droits
à la condition de la femme et il n'y a
pas que les français qui ont été
sensibles je sais que vous êtes très
préoccupé par nous avons eu l'occasion
de discuter de l'intégrisme j'ai été
très frappée parce que tous les textes
intégristes que l'on que l'on voit
maintenant en tunisie en algérie en
particulier son centre est polarisée sur
la question de la femme sur l'idée que
l'occident
c est une source de sourire les
dépravations qu'il n'y a plus de respect
pour la femme que la femme est sujet
aussi de l'homme et ce mouvement au lieu
de se dissoudre au contact de l'occident
semble se renforcer
et c'est peut-être ça qu'il ya dans
l'inconscient à la fois de ceux qui se
crispe sur une laïcité pas en profondeur
comme vous disiez et la fois sur ceux
qui brandissent une réaction contre
foudres contre l'occident alors que lors
la question c'est quel est selon vous à
l'égard de la femme la position de
l'islam la position du maroc la fois
dans sa situation vis-à-vis de la
société de l'homme de son rôle et est ce
que l'occident considère constitue une
sorte d' agression contre une forme de
statue que la femme aurait selon la loi
si vous permettez coranique il serait
avoir d'interprétation ni d'imams need
émir des croyants ni de moufti ni de
quiconque
quand la loi soit coranique soit celle
des traditions du prophète est clair le
prophète a dit très clairement l'homme
et la femme sont des frères siamois
devant les droits et les obligations ni
rien qui justifie la suggestion de la
fera rien ni la sphère du rituel rien ne
vous deja ont petit à petit exemple ceux
de tout temps la femme chez nous a pu
exercer une profession séparer de tout
temps elle a pu disposer de son argent
chez vous ça n'a commencé qu'en 36 et 48
je faisais mon droit ce mot je me rappel
des dates
rien n'oblige la femme a déclaré
l'argent sous marine et quand la femme
veut quand une femme hérite ou qu'elle a
son argent elle a le droit de choisir
l'administrateur qu'elle veut que son
mari soit d'accord metric la
civilisation arabo-musulmane conduit la
phrase la femme à une discrétion à
l'enfermement relatifs à certaines
sociétés à un enfermement relatif dans
une certaine société commence là les
pays musulmans que je traverse sont
souvent des pays où la femme est absente
parce que tout simplement ils n'ont pas
ils n'ont pas mis les lunettes qu'il
fallait pour lire leur texte
donc tous donc donc il ya une force
sociale tout de même qu'on ne peut pas
sous-estimer
moi je pense que notre société très bien
équilibrée l'a toujours été et durer ce
qu'on venait à casablanca que vous êtes
invités à rabat casablanca le raja voir
j'en vois beaucoup moins vous en voyez
beaucoup vos des professeurs des patrons
de maisons d'assurance des banques et
des femmes de commerce des médecins des
spécialistes et nous faisons tout aux
contrées pour les encourager vous
admettez que l'intégrisme et le
fondamentalisme où se réfugient comme
dans un hamac sociaux moi je pense que
la france a une chance dans ce domaine
c'est d'être plus riche que l'onglet en
anglais non culmont intégristes
fondamentalisme le français a le monde
intégristes et fondamentalistes
le maroc est fondamentaliste c'est pour
ça qu'il est sunnite et qui n'a qu'un
seul reid qui le rite malikite donc nous
sommes fondamentalistes mais justement
le fondamentalisme nous interdit
d'intégrer alors on va passer à un autre
sujet si vous voulez on célèbre beaucoup
d'anniversaires en ce moment et tout
d'un coup le fait qu'il va frapper ses
colonnes à oublier un ya trente ans en
c'était l'année de la décolonisation 17
pays ont accédé à l'indépendance et le
monde l'europe l'occident ont regardé
vers ces pays nouvellement indépendants
espérant une certaine sagesse se
penchant sur ses besoins aujourd'hui 30
ans après ce même monde regarde avec une
plus grande considération du fait un
sentiment d'échec dont vous allez me
dire ce que vous en pensez
si les pays de l'est qui s'émancipent
avec cette dimension épique que vous
savez elle reste que les question c'est
qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce set
sentiment d'échec de trente années après
l'indépendance
n'avez-vous pas de crainte que l'europe
l'occident le monde s'intéresse
davantage aux pays de l'est aux dépens
des pays du maghreb pour parler non pas
parler du tiers monde en général et
qu'elle est votre sentiment
sans qu'ils vendent un sentiment de
soulagement de grande admiration pour
monsieur gorbatchev qui n'a pas manqué
de le dire mais mon occasion les plus
solennels à l'ouverture du parlement par
exemple en attirant l'attention de nos
des représentants de ce pays en leur
disant attention
revoyez revoyez les foyers les foyers de
vos jumelles tout change
analyser autrement personnellement je ne
peux qu'applaudir de voir que dorénavant
ce qui se passe ne fait que renforcer
mon idée géopolitique celle que j'avais
toujours à savoir qu'il n'y aurait plus
de conflits horizontaux en europe et je
me disais à à partir du moment où il n'y
a plus de conflits horizontaux parce que
les ailes les autres avaient des têtes
nucléaires aussi détruit les unes que
les autres mon dieu mon dieu que va-t-il
se passer votre verticaux tout ce monde
là bas se défouler verticalement
grâce à dieu personne ne se défoulent
plus ni verticalement mais on parlait de
l'europe et ses répercussions sur le
maghreb
quand j'ai eu le plaisir de présider ici
la conférence françafrique du suivi des
mises à part étrangers en présence de
monsieur roland dumas il était là j'ai
prononcé un discours et j'ai dit aux
africains
surtout que ce rapprochement est ouest
nouveau spot qui nous fait pas peur au
contraire
préparez vos pôles rendez vous car
l'europe s'est faite bien tranquillement
pour 92 sur un matelas de clientèle de
330 millions et la voilà qui peut se
retrouver avec un marché de 700 millions
de consommateurs la différence veulent
apprendre
c'est dire que nos pommes de terre
seront plus arrêté au printemps on verra
on verra d'un autre oeil nous orange nos
goûts jeans
notre notre manufacture notre artisanat
tout ce que nous produirons non matières
premières et je le dise aux africains
soient ya près car il y à un vide qu'il
faudra remplir et à marcher de 330
millions ne se reconvertit pas du jour
au lendemain pour 780 là nous sommes là
aussi tranquille que les choses
moi je vois cet aspect de la vie
beaucoup de sérénité on m'a dit ce que
vous pensiez sur le sentiment d'échec
des 30 années
pardon vous m'aviez pas dit ce que vous
pensez sur le sentiment d'échec sur les
trente années
sur les trente années près de 2 des pays
de l'est non sur les trente années des
pays qui se sont des colonisés et sur
lesquels on pariait avec tellement
d'expérience mais vous savez ce n'est
pas de leur faute ce journal je peux
m'étendre cinq minutes ou deux minutes
le dessus ce sont des pans de vue rieuse
mais je pense que c'est très important
les français les anglais quel autre pays
européen débarque en afrique et tout à
coup sans demander à personne son avis
il apporte les trois pouvoirs
la république le parlement et ainsi de
suite et des frontières qui sont coupés
à la règle coupant des tribus ont deux
coupons des sociétés alors que ces gens
n'allaient jamais entendu parler du
système
bon c'était le chef qui gouvernait avec
le consensus
nous savons nous nous avons prouvé
qu'avec ces pays d'afrique
et quand la colonisation est parti alors
ils sont revenus à leurs moeurs mer
l'état moderne
le chef du clan n'est plus resté sur du
clan 1012 chef du parti unique
la séparation des pouvoirs qui n'avaient
jamais pratiqué pour que voulez vous
quand ils ont trouvé le moyen de la
remettre à leur goût c'est à mon avis
leur jeter la pierre aux jeunes qui
n'ont jamais été préparé à cela je pense
qu'il faut le rendre cette justice et
maintenant du reste le choix est plus
facile peau ça sera plus dur là mon avis
les 180 degrés qu'ils vont faire
ce qu'ils sont faibles seront beaucoup
plus difficiles à traverser que ce
l'union soviétique mais les pauvres ils
enverront des vertes et des pas mûres il
faudrait qu'on dise et les pays
d'afrique parle on parle en parlant avec
le président mitterrand et au nom des
arabes
est ce que votre position n'est pas un
tout petit peu plus malaisée depuis que
l'union du maghreb uni ne peut pas ne
pas se ressentir une recrudescence de la
sphère saharienne et donc de vos
rapports avec l'algérie pour être plus
carrée que peut-être vous me voulez
lettre ces gens d'anemzi nous surveiller
un beau matin et puis j'ai écrit comme
ça une phrase que dont j'ai fait mon
leitmotiv qui est la suivante il faut
savoir gérer les inconvénients des vaste
dessein j'en parlais pour le sahara
c'est encore plus valable pour le magret
bons mecs du terme vont baver encore
peut-être deux ans trois ans quatre ans
mais rien ne dure ni le bon nul mauvais
on ne pouvons pas être plus au creux de
la vague nous sommes actuellement dans
vos rapports avec l'algérie
oui je pense et d'une façon générale or
donc ce que les choses changent
on sait ça ne peut aller que vers
l'au-delà sinusoïde on va être au plus
prêt à vivre dans l'espérance que monde
après avoir vécu dans l'angoissé vie
dans l'expérience mais tout homme d'état
tout chef d'état tout pour responsable
d'une entreprise se doit d'être
optimiste
s'il n'est pas au petit les pessimistes
il vaut mieux qu'il aille prendre sa
neuvaine définit sa retraite définitive
nous éprouvons quelque part est-ce que
vous placez dans ces mots inévitable et
à gérer les affaires dans le monde arabe
souffle c'est à dire le liban d'abord et
ensuite
israël et les palestiniens et pour
cerner la question est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que les accords de taef
dont vous avez été l'un des initiateurs
faisant partie de la commission
tripartite n'ont pas fait trop de
concessions à la syrie et croyez-vous la
syrie consciente est capable de
respecter
personnellement s'il n'avait pas cru la
syrie je vais commencer par la deuxième
s'il n'avait pas cru la syrie capable
d'un minimum de crédibilité
j'aurais dit aux deux chefs d'état qui
sont des amis que soient les problèmes
que j'ai avec l'algérie le président
chef de l'état nomme qui m'est très cher
et de mes témoins que nous aimons
beaucoup
j'aurais dit au creux de l'oreille tu es
né saison passée par appel la série
n'acceptera jamais nous l'avons tous
crédités chacun pour sa part crédité
d'un minimum de sérieux et de volonté de
faire mais il n'ya pas que la syrie il
ya les libanais eux mêmes
il ya ce faux problème des chrétiens et
des noms et des et des non chrétiens il
y à la présence de problème de l' onu
devrait vrai problème mais c'est un faux
problème ils ont vécu là pendant des
siècles
mais ce que vous pourrez contribuer à
empêcher le bon sens comment est-ce que
vous pourrez contribuer à empêcher le
bel sans qu'on nous annonce tous les
jours tant qu'il reste un espoir ce jean
daniel tant qu'il reste un espoir c'est
c'est dans cette partie du globe et du
monde que je mettrai le plus de mes
efforts modestes entre autres car les
fils d'abraham
les adorateurs de dieu on a l'occasion
de montrer qu'ils peuvent vivre frère
comme ils l'ont vécu et qui peuvent
faire quelque chose ce sont ceux là
qu'il faut aider vous êtes seul moyen
que nous avons des chapelles intégrisme
et un intégrisme à remous car vous aussi
vous avez votre intégrisme dans l'église
oui dernière question écouter à moins
que vous vous demandiez à virieu de
prolonger majesté vous êtes depuis 29
ans maintenant vous presque en tout cas
ça fait 4 septennat lequel nous étions
quelques-uns nous étions quelques uns à
vous prévoir quelques années à notre
confusion et maintenant notre joie ça
démonte une instabilité je crois que je
vous ai discuté que par le président
houphouët boigny
comment cette stabilité devant de
l'autorité cette autorité est toujours
le fruit de quelques bavures alors il ya
des gens qui vous aiment qui vous
respecte qui savent reconnaître le rôle
que vous jouez comme interlocuteur de
tous cas doublons force de paix dans le
monde et qui disent tout bas qui espère
votre clémence sur un certain nombre de
problèmes
je sais je crois savoir que les choses
sont en préparation
et pour ne pas les comprendre seulement
pour ne pas les compromettre j'accepte
ne pas les citer mais on espère le
retour de certains enfants le retour de
certains
prisonnier et je pense que c'est digne
d'un roi tel qu'il est décrit par tous
deux d'avoir des gestes de clémence que
pour ma part j'attends comme vous savez
à chacun de nos entretiens
vous me prenez vous ne prenez pas le
côté le plus faible se vend le
narcissisme tout homme est narcissique
monsieur jean des si je pouvais servir
la cause notre narcissisme je suis en
vie sans pour autant que je me noie car
je n'ai pas de neef échos mais je vous
dirais tout simplement ce sens et que
tout ce qui peut n'ont pas amélioré mon
image ou et ceux qui restent devant moi
et certainement moins que ce qui est
passé mais ce que je veux surtout c'est
que mon comportement soit un livre qu'on
puisse lire clairement et dans lequel on
puisse duquel on puisse se retirer
quelques enseignements et soyez assurés
que moi je suis d'abord profondément je
suis un homo foncièrement le prophète
disait qu'il ne se mettait en colère et
c'était un homme boulot si comme tous
les saints et les prophètes qu'il ne se
mettait en colère que lorsqu étaient
violées les enseignements sacro-sainte
du bon alors comme vous dites des choses
mûrissent les sondés mûrir les saint
pierrois majesté je n'ai pas prononcé le
nom est ce que vous vous me donner un
espoir ont fait faux pas toujours vous
prévaloir de notre amitié pour aller
plus loin qu'il n'a jamais
mais vous et godasses u21 a suggéré
bruno raymond abitur je me suis senti
beaucoup plus de devoirs et d'ailleurs
ils sont tous venus chez moi aux
mécontents ah bon bb oui va falloir que
je vous écoute dans ce cas n'a pas
besoin d'y aller nous en reparlerons
mais je si j'aurais pu vous dire
monsieur jean-daniel ne parlons pas de
ce problème on sait faire le leur où les
gens ne peut parler comment ce genre
peut parler c'est suffisant je pose
merci jean daniel l'on retourne on a
ajouté d'autres questions geneviève moll
tout à fait beaucoup d'autres questions
et une questio majesté qui revient assez
souvent
le rapport d'amnesty 89 est accablant
pour le maroc et notamment pour les
tortures dans les prisons
n'êtes vous pas majesté troublé par ce
rapport que comptez vous faire pour
remédier si les torture existe dans vos
prisons je ne sais pas madame qu'il sera
le quel est mon taux de crédibilité dans
ce domaine mais je puis vous assurer une
chose c'est que si je savais que le 1 %
de ce qui est écrit dans ce rapport que
je n'ai jamais lu existe et je puis vous
assurer que je n'en dormirais pas que je
ferai d'abord ce qu'il faudrait pour que
cela cesse deuxièmement non là c'est
très grave c'est pour ça qu'ils ne sont
pas venus
j'ai fait demander amnistie
internationale de venir étudier fait
demander officiellement il était demandé
personnellement par beaucoup d'amis dont
un très cher ici assis à ma droite nous
ce job elle parlé de ce problème et il
m'a dit le savez j'en parle jusqu'à
marocain j'en parle avec autant
d'indignation que vous faites quelque
chose je lui dis rien rendez nous
service dit amnesty de venir et j'ai dit
à mon ministre de l'intérieur de leur
écrire je les attends toujours en fait
quand même vous avez bien parmi vos
téléspectateurs dès sémiologue je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas la tête d'un bonhomme
qui torturent ils torturent à longueur
de journée qu'ils aient tous le moyen de
dormir de bien faire son travail
de rire de sourire d'embrasser ses
enfants et d'avoir le culot pas dessus
de match et d'aller serrer les mains de
chefs d'état alors j'attends que mes
skis internationale c'est elle qui
répondra et je pense qu'elle sera
confondu la majesté nous allons
enchaîner avec un autre sondage qui
concerne la question posée pour un pays
comme le maroc
pensez vous que le changement en europe
santander au sens de changements dans
les pays de l'est aussi bien que dans la
communauté ont des effets positifs
négatifs cent d'opinions positives 63%
négatif de 13 % sans opinion
24 % c'est donc si vous voulez un
domaine dans lequel votre argumentation
est très partagé par les français du roi
ou un quart d'heure ça passe vite
sa femme va se farcir nom sonne j'aurai
encore des questions à poser aux chefs
d'état que vous êtes aux chefs religieux
vous êtes mais je voudrais commencer par
quelques questions qui s'adresse à
l'homme que vous êtes aussi vous êtes
souverain vous vivez dans un palais dans
lequel nous sommes qui est magnifique
entourée de beaucoup de respect de
beaucoup de déférence
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas terriblement
solitaire d'abord le le respect et du
mais il n'existe que si on est un homme
respectable
je connais beaucoup de personnes
auxquelles le respect du ne sont pas
respectées une question d anthologie de
conduite
je dois vous dire une chose c'est que
tout homme qui prend une décision
quelque échelon qu'elle soit quand il a
quitté ses conseillers ses amis à ses
parents et qu'il doit prendre une
décision il arrive un moment où il est
seul quelle que soit la position où la
responsabilité qu'il est quand on me dit
que j'ai pas moi que staline que brejnev
groupe shell étaient des athées j'ai dit
non je dis non parce que quel que soit
le nombre de chars qu'est-ce que soit le
nombre de têtes nucléaires quel que soit
le nombre de soldats que l'on puisse
savoir qu'on soit au kremlin et lisa
buckingham palace dans l'ain street ou
ou la maison blanche où le modeste
palais de rabat puisque ne vont pas la
taille de ces grands pays il arrive un
moment on se tourne vers le grand patron
chacun l'appelle sa puissance et de sa
façon mais on est toujours le seul
est-ce que vous avez autour de vous pour
poser la question plus précisément des
hommes ou des femmes qui peuvent qui ose
vous dire vous avez tort vous faites
bêtise vous allez prendre une mauvaise
décision vous avez pris une mauvaise
décision est ce que vous avez des gens
autour de vous qui vous critiquent salon
puisqu'il ya un phénomène de court le
problème se pose à tous les chefs d'état
nous avait accordée à l'elysée on en
parle aussi il y en a nous d'accord
dans ce cas la décision que j'ai à
prendre sont de deux sortes faut pas
oublier que j'ai deux femmes
la grande et la petite famille ma grande
famille c'est mon peuple
dans ce domaine je ne prends jamais une
décision seul ce qui fait que je ne
mettrai jamais à ce qu'on me dise mais
comment il hier soir vous été comme ça
et ce matin vous a pris de décision je
me permets jamais de prendre décision
seul quand il s'agit de ma grande
famille par contre quand cegid quitte à
me contacter à terre familiale et chante
à exercer mon droit librement quand
j'estime qu'il faut l'exercer et
quelquefois il m'arrive de prendre ma
décision seul et alors là effectivement
dans le cède ma petite famille le revers
de la médaille je n'ai que ce que je
mérite on me dit avec plus de respect de
la nature ils m'ont soutenu je pense que
vous avez eu tort de faire telle chose
mais dans la grande famille on vous le
jeune parce que je ne prends pas mais je
ne prendrai mes décisions
il m'est arrivé de prendre une mauvaise
décision j'ai toujours eu le courage de
revenir sur ses décisions
est ce que la presse marocaine a le
droit de vous critiquer n'a pas su pas
mise en équation
je ne suis pas éligibles et je ne suis
électeur que lorsqu'il s'agit préférable
donc ma personne n'ait à mise en
équation ni dans les îles et les
législatures législatives ni dans les
présidentielles ni dans les communales
ni dans les partiels mais vous êtes un
chef d'état et un chef d'état qui a
beaucoup de pouvoirs réels
il serait donc assez logique dans un
pays qui veut être une démocratie que la
presse puisse le critiquer et vos
décisions
elle me critiquent naturellement déjà
j'admire la critique jeu requiert un
minimum de respect dans l'expression de
cette fille
hic car je suis moi même un homme bien
élevé et lorsque cette presse critique
la gym dit deux choses l'une où tu
considères que tu dois la prendre en
compte
et dans ce cas la pilule alli mais si tu
as pas la prendre en compte pourquoi la
ligue du nord à partir du monde je lis
et de presse judo donc la honte et j'ai
pour rectifier le tir
un gouvernement des institutions
démocratiques parlementaire ou
régionales et je puis vous assurer que
lorsque l'opposition par exemple dans le
cas de l'opposition deux fois
l'opposition parlementaire
de par la constitution a demandé mon
arbitrage et deux fois j'ai vendu mon
arbitrage et ce n'était pas par
démagogie au parc flatterie mais les
deux fois dans ma vie où j'ai dû me
rendre mon arbitrage par écrit
ça a été au profit non pas de la
majorité mais l'opposition
je change tout à fait sujet et je
voudrais qu'on parle un instant ceci dit
je viens vous dire une chose c'est que
je ne tolérerai jamais sur le plan du
respect des gens et des hommes et des
institutions
une presse comme le canard enchaîné ou
autres quel que soit le respect que j'ai
pour monsieur traîneau le grand monsieur
traîneau mais ce genre de presse je ne
tenais pas alors la semaine n'est pas
dans notre environnement
donc cette liberté de la presse là ne va
pas jusque là quand même
la caricature chez nous et est quasiment
interdite par consensus national
mais la caricature de la politique que
vous menez par exemple dans la
caricature d'un homme était un homme à
l'accord non mais bon tout le monde
touche pas aux sommes d'accord entente
politesse est vrai que vous parler un
peu des relations entre la france et le
maroc et particulièrement des relations
économiques les la part de la france
dans les échanges commerciaux entre les
deux pays a tendance à décroître d'année
en année est-ce que vous avez une
explication pourquoi ça se passe comme
ça
est ce que vous le regrettez le tueur et
mandats brm d'abord je ne regrette
effectivement dans certains domaines
mais c'est sectorielle et c'est contre
balancer et je dois dire que depuis les
années 70 jusqu'à nos jours
nous n'avons pas eu de réels problèmes
économiques ou financiers avec la france
doit dire que nous avons vu vraiment de
la part des différents gouvernements
français qui sont succédé la plus grande
compréhension mature helmand la france
elle même n'est pas tellement libre de
ses mouvements depuis qu'elle s'est mise
dans l'engrenage de l'europe elle même à
une certaine certaines limitations dans
ses actions brument fonctionne
empêcherait pas les entreprises
françaises de faire preuve de davantage
de dynamisme ici par face à la
concurrence américaine par exemple mais
personne ne les empêche de venir
non mais vous trouvez qu'ils sont un peu
timides
comment vous trouvez qu'ils sont un peu
timides non je dois dire qu'il n'avait
pas peut-être tout le confort qu'ils
espéraient maintenant toutes les
barrières ont été enlevés y compris la
gestion directe de leurs propres
affaires
il y à un certain nombre de pays dans le
monde où l'amitié pour la france où la
culture française était très développé
et où petit à petit elle s'est amoindrie
la francophonie est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que la francophonie reste
aussi vivace au maroc qu auparavant
est ce que vous pouvez imaginer un maroc
qui évoluerait comme d'autres pays
encore en s'éloignant de la francophonie
non je ne pense pas qu'il aurait un
éloignement de la francophonie je pense
qu'il aurait un enrichissement de cette
francophonie parle hispanophone ou
l'anglophonie mais je pense qu'il y aura
toujours une attirance assez
particulière pour les francophones
encore faut-il que la francophonie nous
aide aussi un petit peu par la qualité
de ses enseignants alors justement c'est
la question que je voulais vous poser
est ce que ça va de ce côté là ça va
mieux ça va mieux que lui serviront bien
entendre ça va mieux ça va mieux depuis
depuis à peu près 8 9 mois ça va
beaucoup mieux qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous qu'est-ce qui vous ennuyer dans
ce qui s'est passé avant c'était la
qualité c'était le comportement des
enseignants des coopérants français
les deux mais de la qualité n'était pas
assez formés et le comportement il
venait presque passer des vacances pour
partir est ce parce qu'ils étaient trop
jeunes une dernière question sur la
france dont il est plus que temps de la
pause et puisqu'on nous sommes dans les
derniers jours de décembre
la france viennent de fêter le
bicentenaire de sa révolution de 1789
c'est un anniversaire qui vous a
concerné oui puisque vous allez dépenser
j'ai été même j'étais même surpris ne
pas être invité alors on n'a pas évité
les monarchies je le sens je crois que
ça suffit si la france était régi site
ne passait pas de ma faute et puis il
faut que tu reviens ce que ce que vient
faire la présence de nos présences des
rois moi aussi j'ai été vexé
j'ai été vexé de ne pas être invité
j'aurais tellement voulu y aller devrait
revenir un instant à certaines questions
sur les rapports avec l'islam qui ont
déjà été abordées tout à l'heure est ce
que dans le fond de vous même vous avez
le sentiment de partager la même
religion que d'autres musulmans qui dans
certains autres pays du monde et à paris
pas nombreux mais à paris ont défilé
dans les rues en criant à la guerre
sainte
par exemple est-ce que la guerre sainte
fait partie de l'islam elle le faisait
elle faisait partie de l'islam lorsqu'il
islam étaient une poignée qu'il fallait
qu'il y ait une expansion mais depuis
lors il a une une évolution
ce n'est pas parce que les arabes sont
devenus moins fort qu'ils sont devenus
plus pacifiques non problème n'est pas
là non pas du tout mais il certain que
je me sens frère de tout musulman qui
dit qu' il n'y a qu' il n'y a de dieu
que dieu nous prophète mahomet tél
1 mais à partir du moment où par leur
comportement agressif non tolérant non
progressiste non prospectifs ce matin à
défigurer ou a vraiment un raccourcir
tous les jours la longueur des pieds de
cette religion je me sens pas très frère
de les franchir
il y a eu des sondages en france
récemment qui demandait est ce que pour
vous l'islam est une religion tolérante
ou intolérantes et massivement les
français disent et intolérante
pas du tout 28 mai ce qu'ils ont est-ce
qu'ils ont quelques raisons objectives
de se tromper
oui oui oui parce qu'ils signent leur
religion
est ce que ce n'est pas aussi parce que
certains musulmans ont donné de la
religion musulmane une apparence
peut-être contraires aux lois
fondamentales mais qui était une
apparence agressive et intolérante
oui alors c'est là où vraiment jeu votre
pays est un pays de génial dans ses
contradictions
oui vous êtes le pays de montesquieu
qu'elle monte ce que bon écrit l'esprit
des lois mais d'un autre côté quand dans
ces lettres persanes et dia comment
monsieur et qu'il perçoit comme si on
pourrait pas être persan sans être
français
vous êtes très contradictoires alors
vous accueillez n'importe qui n'importe
quel charlatans qui défigurent n'importe
qui sous le couvert des droits de
l'homme et de l'asile politique en somme
vous payer la facture de votre grand
trop grande je pense les mots naïveté
d'enfin trop grande hospitalité qui
n'est pas voyante qui n'est pas regarde
donc vous reconnaîtrez qu'il y a dans
toutes les manifestations sélective dans
tout depuis les manifestations de ce
qu'on appelait l'intégrisme musulman des
manifestations assez agressif je me
demande par exemple est ce qu il est
pensable que
qu'il y ait un jour l'équivalent d'un
concile de l'islam un mécène voulant
nous c'est qu'ils la gagnent haut avec
certains avec certaines de nos amis de
la fia et nous avions commencé avant le
khomeynisme entamer un dialogue avec les
les disciples de khomeiny rester en iran
et nous sommes partis du principe sion
en disant ça fait quatorze siècles
l'islam il existe ça fait quatre siècles
qui lie à la soutenaient les chiens
l'ex-militaire non c'est foutu la paix
pendant quatre siècles
et puis un beau matin pour les pour ceux
qui me connaissent pas bien la sonas
c'est la tradition sunitinib relâché à
cergy c'est les chutes c'est une c'est
une hérésie
c'est une erreur je dis voilà il a suffi
qu'un monsieur à paris ce qui s'appelle
roumanie pour qu'immédiatement ce métal
à se taper dessus
alors qu'on a vécu en très bon frère pas
montrer ses cartes 14 siècles reprenons
le dialogue et je crois que là bas les
cheese et qui l'ont comprise est ce qu
un concile comme celui là pourrait
donner à l'islam une nouvelle unité
ça pourrait lui donner ça lui donnera
pas de l'unicité mais ça lui donnerait
unités et ça lui donnera certainement
une un lexique commun payer un
dictionnaire commun en ce qui concerne
le comportement dans les rapports et la
communauté musulmane en france il y a un
problème c'est souvent un manque
d'interlocuteurs l'ancien recteur de la
mosquée de paris qui est décédé avait un
jour souhaité la création en france de
ce qu'il avait appelé un organisme de
référence de la communauté musulmane une
espèce bon d'église musulmanes en france
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
semble souhaitable non moi tout ce que
je sais c'est que à paris je vais
profiter de ce passage à paris je vais
ni considèrent que l'église la mosquée
de paris bon nous n'en parle plus je
vais demander pourquoi pourquoi vous ne
parlez plus elle verra demain
d'abord il est un peu vieille
deuxièmement jean peuple c'est un
contentieux de comptabilité que nos amis
téléspectateurs français de haut qu'il
ne s'intéresserait pas en tout cas de la
façon dont vous en parler peut pas
comprendre je vous dira tout simplement
c'est plus qu'un conflit par exemple
avec l'algérie à propos des postes mais
non avec ses noces qui a été inauguré en
1990 par mon grand père c'est le maroc a
donné les trois quarts des subsides pour
que la mosquée soit payée sur les a
boostés trois pays algérie maroc tunisie
et depuis que cette mosquée existe
jamais la direction des revenus au maroc
car si kaddour benghabrit est que dieu
ait son âme qui était quand même
et c'était un algérien bien qu'ils
étaient des fonctionnaires marocains
détaché auprès de mon père en tant que
chef du protocole je compte demander
avec l'autorisation de ce président de
la république à monsieur chirac de nous
vendre un terrain et nous allons par
souscription construire une mosquée où
nous mettrons un imam marocain sunnites
et vous verrez à lancement là comme gars
comme lorsqu'il ya une meule de foin non
égrainé que le vent séparera de lui-même
la bonne graine et que tout ce qui est
payé autre ira de notre terre et vous
verrez que tous les bons musulmans
viendront pour la plupart dans la
mosquée
et si le maire de de marseille persiste
dans sa très bonne volonté de faire une
mosquée nous sommes prêts à le faire et
je dis même plus je sais qu'il a des
français de souche qui sont musulmans
de père en fils si je trouve un français
assez au fait de la religion musulmane
pour prendre en main cette église sans
qu'ils soient marocains je préfère
qu'ils soient français et qu'il la
dirige
j'ai demandé tout simplement d'apprendre
à mettre la djellaba
le tarbouche pour que les voir les gens
le voile vendredi en blanc et qu'il
dessus population prier mais je
souhaiterais encore sa une une dernière
question
elle vous avez sera peut-être mais il ya
des français
cela pose alors creusé la question agace
on fait notre métier là là là très très
grande mosquée que vous faites
construire à casablanca
oui est ce que ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui est un peu la religion c'est
évidemment très important il faut des
temples des églises des cathédrales des
mosquées pour l'exercer mais est ce que
ce n'est pas comment dire par l'argent
qui est dépensé et qui a été obtenu en
grande partie par les entreprises ou par
le peuple marocain est ce que ce n'est
pas quelque chose d'un peu trop grand
trop riche trop fastueux pour un peuple
qui a encore des problèmes de
développement et de pauvreté
votre question totalement des places
totalement déplacé parce que je puis
vous dire une chose si vous veniez à
calculer le nombre des mosquées qui
existent au maroc
elles se comptent par centaines de
milliers toutes ont été construits par
ce studio on parlait du volume de sel la
mort et le et de son prix comment et de
son prix ou naturellement alors
remettons les choses dans d'heure dans
leur contexte historique et que pensez
vous de notre dame de paris dans le
contexte français économique français
quand l'a construite à mes oreilles
peut-être peut-être été celui-là vrai
jeu par la défense et je ne veux pas en
parler c'est un très beau c'est un très
grand monument mais peut-être les une
erreur économique
comment peut être était ce une erreur
économique d'un côté nous sommes dans un
monde de libre expression
vous avez la liberté de le dire tout
laisse toutes les souscriptions ont été
libre tout les taxations pour financer
cette mosquée ont été libres volontaire
mais la question peut-être déplacer
comment l'agression est peut-être encore
déplacées nous avons un ennui
actuellement mais j'espère retirer de la
circulation judiciaire nous avons un nom
avec le journal le monde à cause de cela
je pense que vous devez y est allé les
trouver pour leur demander ce qu'ils en
pensent mais nous allons de toute façon
vu les relations entre temps avec le
général le journal le monde
nous avons décidé de retirer notre
planète majesté pour vous commandeur des
croyants est ce que la
déchristianisation de l'europe et de la
france
est ce que c'est une bonne chose parce
que c'est une mauvaise et nous ait
choisis très mauvaise nous réchauffe
parce que nous parlons plus d'une
langage particulièrement lorsqu'il
s'agit de critiquer mon temps qu'une
manque de valeurs spirituelles manque
oui mais quand nous parlons de la vierge
marie
il n'y a pas de différence entre un
musulman sunnite et chrétiens qu'ils
soient catholiques ou qu'ils soient
protestants
quand nous disons que le christ est venu
souffler le verbe et le souffle de dieu
ce ski est dans le coran considérons
comme n'étant pas loin de l'orthodoxie
catholique protestant et c'est vraiment
ça une seule ça nous prive de
correspondance de correspondants de
professionnels ou est ce que veut bien
nous allons retourner asvp pour deux
dernières questions
geneviève moll question que se posent
beaucoup de spectatrices pourquoi ne
connaîtront pas la reine du maroc ma
course
on n'a plus raison c'est que depuis que
le maroc et maroc
il n'y a jamais eu draine tous nos
mariages ont été morganatique et je
pense que toutes les dynasties qui se
sont succédé ont fait là un choix très
judicieux
dieu nous a évité les régences féminine
qui n'ont pas toujours été très heureuse
de par le monde alors donc voilà je vous
dis pourquoi cette news zico
par contre quand j'ai l'occasion de
présenter la mer des princes qui porte
le titre de princesse mais qui n'ont pas
celui de rennes qui n'a aucune activité
politique
comme ce fut le cas de la femme de
moules et délices premier en passant par
toutes les autres dynasties h la
présente très normalement ce que
j'estime qu'elle est qu'elle est bien
élevé qu'elle est très présentable et
dernière question mais c'était face à la
menace du terrorisme international
participeriez vous un axe de coopération
et de défense
engageant le maroc l'espagne et la
france un acte de défense contre le
terrorisme international
et pourquoi seulement nous trois
d'accord je supprime mais nous faisons
déjà partie d'un club qui s'appelle le
club de trévise niel que n'étant pas
européen nous sommes parmi les pays qui
exceptionnellement en faisant partie et
nous sommes très heureux d'assumer cette
responsabilité qui est une
responsabilité historique et humaine
elle ne fait pas partie de ce club qui
veut et je suis très heureux que le
manque était disons choisi et les
professeurs type club de trevi qui s'est
réunit d'ailleurs avoir tué marie avec
monsieur basri et notre ministre de
l'intérieur y est voilà majesté nous
avons l'habitude de clore cette émission
par le verdict de la sofres vers le
verdict des téléspectateurs français et
c'est jérôme jaffré directeur des études
politiques la sofres qui a fait
d'ailleurs ce soir une performance
technique je crois qu'il faut souligner
qui va le présenter jérôme jaffré ça
dépend des réponses qui peut vous donner
guérini s'est ouvert sur mon fric ni
coupure des sondages nous avons tout de
même posé tout au long de l'émission des
questions pour mesurer au fond les
traits d'image du maroc de l'islam et
voir comment ils ont évolué alors
première question posée en début et en
fin d'émission sur les traits d'image du
maroc tels que l'opinion française
les perçoit les principaux traits
d'image le maroc pays développés ou
encore peu développés qui a beaucoup peu
d'influencé sur la scène internationale
qui respecte bien ou mal les droits de
l'homme nous avons posé cette série de
qualificatifs et voici les résultats en
fin d'émission les traits principaux qui
s'applique au maroc d'abord pour les
français c'est encore un pays peu
développés 47% peu d' influence sur la
scène internationale 28% et qui respecte
mal les droits de l'homme 28% les cela
dit les résultats sont partagés sur l'
influence internationale beaucoup 28 peu
26 sur les droits de l'homme ils ont
évolué assez sensiblement tout de même
en cours d'émission puisqu'en début
d'émission 33 % de l'échantillon de la
sofres estimé que le maroc respecte mal
les droits de l'homme nous sommes tombés
à 28 en fin d'émission 11% estimé que le
maroc respecte bien les droits de
l'homme 20% en fin d'émission donc une
certaine évolution
même si tout de même ce sont des traits
d'image négatif qui sortent plutôt en
tête
deuxième question les traits d'image
concernant l'islam
on sait combien le sujet en france
aujourd'hui est délicat et important
là aussi nous avons posé une série de
mots qui s'applique à l'islam
violence ou paix progrès ou retour en
arrière fanatisme ou tolérance dont
parlait tout à l'heure albert du roy
là les jugements sont particulièrement
sévères c'est les résultats en fin
d'émission que nous vous montrons
fanatisme 68% retour en arrière 45%
violence 35% et les très positif paye
seulement 7% progrès 4% tolérance 9%
il ya une très légère évolution en cours
d'émission
mais malgré les propos de sa majesté
l'image de l'islam ne s'est pas
véritablement modifier
elle reste extrêmement marqué dans
l'inconscient collectif français
actuellement troisième question est-ce
que entre le maroc et les autres pays
arabes
les ressemblances ou les différences
l'emportent est ce qu'il ya surtout des
ressemblances ou des différences
réponse en fin d'émission 59% des
français estiment qu'il ya beaucoup de
différences entre le maroc et les autres
pays arabes 35% seulement les
ressemblances l'emportent
on voit ici donc comment coexistent
finalement la sympathie pour le maroc et
l'opinion très critique sur l'islam qui
existent puisque au fond mais le maroc
un petit peu à part des autres pays
islamiques
dernière question c'est l'opinion à
l'égard de sa majesté
elle peut paraître incongru car comme le
disait le roi tout à l'heure il ne peut
pas être mis en équation
mais comme c'est notre tradition au
cours de cette émission nous l'avons
fait tout de même
et l'équation est plutôt positive
puisque en fin d'émission
73 % de l'échantillon de la sofres pour
qu'une bonne opinion sur le roi hassan 2
16% une mauvaise en début d'émission
nous enregistrions 45 % de bonnes
opinions
18 % de mauvaises ce qui est intéressant
à noter c'est en fin d'émission nous
constatons que parmi les sympathisants
de gauche 63 % déclarent avoir une bonne
opinion du roi ou parmi les français de
moins de 35 ans qui composent notre
échantillon 65 % ont une bonne opinion
du roi également donc un assez large
consensus
comme on le dit en conclusion je noterai
que cette émission à elle seule n'a pas
suffit à modifier un certain nombre
d'idées reçues ou d'image qui existe
actuellement sur l'islam mais qu'elle a
certainement fait évoluer la
compréhension des français ou du moins
des téléspectateurs de ce soir à l'égard
du maroc
majesté monsieur maurice druon guéri
fille parmi vos invités dit que vous
avez l'habitude de terminer vos
conversations avec lui en disant venez
on va rêver à quoi rêvez-vous quand vous
quand vous partez comme ça avec lui
maintenant j'ai un autre rêve qui qui
m'apparaît beaucoup plus urgents depuis
les chiffres qu'on vienne nous donner
mon rêve c'est que tous les musulmans du
monde fasse un petit effort sur eux
mêmes comme je lé fais comme je le fais
quotidiennement pour donner une mer aux
finances de même car en définitive nous
sommes tous des hommes comme les autres
notre religion nous n'aurons ni
meilleure ni pire les autres mais elle
l'est elle nous donne aussi le moment de
force et surtout nos moments de
faiblesse qui font que nous avons le
courage de nous tourner d'abord vers
dieu pour le repentir et vers nos frères
les hommes quelle que soit leur religion
pour leur demander leur compassion et
leur aide
voilà mon rêve et je crois qu'il faut
que je m'y attache et beaucoup de
musulmans sa tâche avec moi à céret
merci majesté c'était donc l'heure de
vérité de sa majesté hassan ii roi du
maroc
prochain rendez vous le 22 janvier avec
monsieur jacques delors bonsoir
[Musique]